hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of entrepreneur tools
where I highlight my favorite tools that
I use to run my business today I'm going
to talk about one of my favorite apps
that I use and it's HootSuite for my
iPad and what I find this very helpful
to do is to manage my Twitter account
when I'm on my laptop or my desktop at
the office I'm usually using HootSuite
to manage on my Twitter accounts anyway
but I find when I'm mobile or I'm at a
conference or a coffee shop and I want
to connect with Twitter I find that the
HootSuite app is very helpful and gonna
quickly show you how I use it and
hopefully there's some ideas for you to
be able to implement the for your
business as well so this is HootSuite
have loaded up here on my iPad I'm gonna
probably zoom in a little bit so maybe
easier to read all the different things
that are happening here yeah so too much
there we go so a back up and I'll just
move it down here so we can see so this
is my HootSuite and at the top you can
pick basically the different fields that
you want to use so the first field that
I have is sent tweets and these are the
tweets that I've sent this is helpful
just to know that anything that I've
scheduled is actually going out okay and
that I can see you know if I need a
history of my my tweet so you can put
that there up to you if you want
included or not the next one that I have
over here is family and so these are
tweets that you know if I want to follow
up with somebody on is fine so this is
my sister who's talking about health
start ups that can respond to her if I
want so again an easy way to be able to
set things up these are through custom
lists so the sent tweets the first one
is done by HootSuite it's one of the
automatic filters you can put in there
the second one is if you create a custom
list and you can do that through Twitter
any person that you want to you know
stay in touch with and build a list you
can just add them to the list and then a
HootSuite say I want to import that list
and have a custom column for it so in
this case it's my family and so this is
my sister Alexandra and I've added her
to my list and so anytime she tweets I
have it here as well I can always see
what she's up to so
you know here she says she's been having
some berries and pumpkin seeds for
dinner that's great I can write back if
I want to that's a great way to just
sustain touch and see what's happening
the next list that I made was for
business so these are some of my
business contacts that I in stay in
touch with and just see what they're up
to so Tasha David a couple more we
scroll down we can see you know more
different tweets and up to me again if I
want to stay in touch with these people
and send them a note or not just see
what they're doing and again you know
quick easy way so this is another list
that I made called business and just
business contacts that I want to stay in
touch with a lot of the business
contacts that I have aren't necessarily
on Twitter or don't have a personal
account so it may be hard to add them on
here but if they do was a great way to
just stay in touch and see what people
are up to and if you you know have a
reason to connect with somebody it's
easy to show it here through that list
so it's great idea to have different
lists for different contacts some of
them maybe more important than others
and so to make sure you don't lose the
stream of people that you're connecting
with you can easily import your list
into here the next thing you can do is
also do it based on keywords so the
first two lists one was from my family
one is for business the next thing that
I have here is for certain keywords so
this is usually I set this up for
keywords that I'm tracking usually for
people who want to be on Twitter or
should be on Twitter I've kind of
convinced them to join but they're not
sold on the idea yet so I've helped them
set up a count we've got some tweets
going on but they're not really
monitoring their account so I'll help
monitor it for them quickly you don't
forget to the point where it's too crazy
to manage I'll hand it over to them but
basically I'm tracking their key name
and any important words that may be
relevant to their business and it's a
great way from you able to be able to
let them know that hey somebody just
tweeted about you or mentioned your name
or mention your company or talking about
your industry and they use that as a way
to stay in touch with people as well so
if you have any keyword that you're
looking for again it could be to
recognize somebody but it could also be
for your own business if there's certain
keywords that are important anytime
somebody tweets about it you can set up
that custom search and then you'll get
the list of all the people who are
tweeting about it and you
respond again most of the stuff I'll do
from my desktop but it's great
especially when you're at a conference
you may be there for a couple days or
you're traveling and you can't get
access easily from a computer
let's pop up the iPad load up HootSuite
and you can get all the all the terms
that you want right there and then
another one close that up another one
here is mentions so these are people who
talk about me so they've mentioned my
name for whatever reason and these are I
find really important this is why I'm
really on Twitter and why it's important
for me to kind of stay on top of what's
going on cuz these are people who are
trying to talk to me and it's important
that I respond at least to some of them
so some of them may be you know junk you
know the first one there says follow me
back somebody said thanks good to know
you don't have to necessarily respond to
everybody but it's up to you to pick
what time what might make sense so
here's an example this guy here is
Andrea we've been working on a little
project and he says here I'll let you
know soon when I will be in front of my
laptop so if you want to respond to
somebody here so this is a good example
I could just click on him
and click on reply let me move this over
so you guys can see what's happening
here so this is this message if I want I
can retweet it I can set it as a
favorite there's other options I could
look at his profile if I want to learn
more but right now I'm gonna click reply
and this will pop up and it says his @
name and he said he's gonna look at on
his laptop so I'll just say thank you
exclamation mark and then click on the
send button and that'll go off to him
so it's this message sent so it's good
it's gone so it's a great way to be able
to quickly update anything if you need
to respond to people so the last thing I
use it for is for hashtags this is
similar to the search and this is very
important when you're at a conference a
lot of times at different conferences
you'll see that they use hashtags and
people are tweeting about the event so
if you want to keep track of what's
going on or if you want to add your own
comments to it you can do a search term
for the hashtag so I put one in here
this was for SES tio was a
a conference that took place in Toronto
search engine strategies for Toronto
that I was media at and was covering and
so I was tweeting with the hashtag and
seeing what people were writing so this
is great if you have internet access at
the conference to be able to quickly see
what other people are writing respond if
you want get involved in the
conversation and kind of keep that live
feed going now it looks like this is
something completely different now this
hashtag it looks like it's something
Italian
so maybe not relevant anymore to what I
was doing but if you're ever at an event
and there is a hashtag it's a great way
to be able to quickly see what people
are writing get involved I've set up
lunch times using a hashtag somebody
talks about them they tweet a message
and you know I agree with it or disagree
with it and I tweet them back and say
hey why don't we have lunch together or
have a coffee and talk about it so it's
a great way to stay in touch and see
what's happening the conversation at
that conference so those are the quick
ways that I use it I find it really
helpful again when I'm mobile that I use
the iPad to quickly see what's going on
so again I use it for if I'm at a
conference using a specific hashtag I
use it to track my mentions and people
are talking about me I'll use it this
track specific keywords that I'm I want
to track and stay on top of I'll use it
to track my different lists so this is a
business list and this is a family list
and then I'll also use it to track sent
tweets that I use that I've posted out
from my account so hopefully that helps
that's how I use HootSuite I found it be
really helpful a great way to stay on
top of my tweets especially when I'm
mobile I'd love to hear how you guys
using it so if you like this video
please give it a thumbs up it'll make me
want to do more of them for you and
share more tools that might help you
grow your business and if you have any
questions or comment about HootSuite or
if you want to share what you're doing
feel free to leave it in the comment
section below I always read those and I
always try to respond to everybody so
thank you and we'll see you on the next
episode
you